so was kind of crazy what would Diplo do
yes you came up with this do you help
come up with well this via this brain
and Germer okay directed every episode
that was tasked with coming up with a
commercial for the Mad Decent block
party which get low and is labeled host
and Brandon's idea was to have me play
West yes like a Dollar Shave Club type
vibe and you know West you're friends
with what I did not know Wes I didn't
know Brandon I didn't know anybody okay
um and so they came to me I looked at
Brandon's real Jen amazing is generally
brilliant talented guy and I said I'll
do that so delivery right on the on the
commercial we shot it lot fun young
hungry crew great people had anyone ever
told you you look like Diplo before no
nobody ever told me I look like this
this is this is just kind of Brandon's
idea okay and then we thought there'd be
the end of it and then my son came to us
and said we think this is a series and I
said no it's not a series come on guys
and then that night I took it seriously
I went back and put some diplom I had
phones and I was like wait a minute this
could be like musical genius suckster
life and so sort of breaking the
characters down Brandon and I forgot to
New York and pitch Spike Jonze Wow
spike said yes and we we had a series
and did you listen to Diplo do you know
anything about Diplo's persona before
that because when I think being a music
guy when I think what would Diplo do I
just think sleep with every girl on the
place that's what I think well if you
follow him on snapchat
there is an element there it is um yeah
I mean I was like wait what Brandon's
idea of having me play was like hey
everybody knows the music here we know
that social media in print and what if
we just got behind that and played with
the idea of the expectation of what this
person's life is really like so that was
when you know when we're writing them it
was like
how do we subvert that expectation a
little bit so we gave a lot of blind
spots personal blind spots
yeah and give him this superpower of
musical genius which everybody wants yes
and we also decided he could channel
wisdom at the look only at the most
inappropriate moments ago in a moment
everybody in room B liked very much of
the wrong screw dude not good genius
genius I like it like a genius in some
way okay so now you also gave him an
attractive assistant yes it obviously
comes with the territory when you're
Diplo so how did you think how did you
sign up for this project um well it was
actually really funny because I had just
gotten done watching olive don't trust
to be an apartment so really strong I
did leave it yeah but a plane achill and
so whenever I saw and I had been wanting
to do something with Vice like in a like
a Travel Show capacity or some sort of
like reality capacity so whenever I was
like oh cool I was like beak yes and
then I just kind of like went in and I
was going to that day by day so I like
when I was like through my sides way
like this was happening and then I got a
call back and I was like okay cool
could put my size back out and uh yeah
and suddenly we did the other audition
and just kind of like got like played
off of each other and you actually met
me in the meeting room you know thanks
so much for coming I was like what never
happened
that's kinda worried about how I got
roped into it I just kind of through a
series of auditions and then she was she
was the one first issues you net are
unanimous choice I yelled at him which
is like this she was on it
she was smart capable and there's also
kind of like oh my god like I roll up
like do you know what I'm doing for you
you understand reality right you
understand where you are and we're like
that's exactly what we want for the skin
so she's yeah rounded everything and
made it she doors character is really
the kind of the audience's eyes in the
world she's the ones
completely sane care sane level-headed
socially how I'm the web landed on it
one when in real life but is so not too
changed I wish I had a Karen to follow
me around so what about you are you
getting to stretch playing this
character because the likely you guys
lived is like something way outside
which crazy yeah but for me the funny
thing is like okay added of this crazy
life but like what happens when they
can't find the coffee yeah so that was
the fun for this this character
familiars are the blind spots and you
know and to the bright spots for this
characters like determining reality from
fantasy vocabulary is a big hurdle for
him or is the real Diplo's actually was
very intelligent a smart um but it was
more fun extinct if Louis was kind of
just kind of a loose and just lived on
another plane of existence when everyone
has this idea of rock stars and whatever
that like it's always like women jugs
and up on party party party where like
whenever you actually like go backstage
and hang out with the band until like
that there's like kids running around
and like maybe their mom is there and
you're just like eating snacks and
hanging out and like watching TV it's
like you get you know that you're really
in the inner circle when you get to do
the boring stuff the maracas crack
different oh yeah and you're just like
sweatpants couch chillin all that yeah
so what about your DJ skills do you DJ I
have you ever I don't I I learned I
learned just enough to be annoying yeah
when because we actually I threw me up
on stage yeah I have just swapped me out
for West at two shows yeah and so he
taught me how to do a little bit behind
the board which he thought was easy is
incredibly complicated for me yeah um
all the better but yeah I saw the
buttons invisible and something like
turn off we at one point I had to go I
he is just so down and take the piss out
of all of it he's like how was story up
there and I got out there I had a
microphone I had a master volume in
front of me I did make a loop like I
could have really
stuff up and at one point I came back
and I was like you know I mean in
disgust up the mat he's a block party
and I hit a button in like oh that was
dated it was about maybe a second and a
half it felt like forever oh yeah
staring at and people staring and just
when you want to be to drop and it's
just crickets
Calvin Harris makes an appearance well
Calvin doesn't there's an accurate an
actor playing Calvin it's not him John
Calvin you're not the first person I
think that was actually Calvin either
oh wow all of it a good job yeah Wow
I'll roll with all the know DJ's play
themselves we all have good actors
playing all the details so is there any
celebrity or any actual musician cameos
of actual people or not well the clothes
always the closest thing we have is
Dillon Francis who is in reality an
amazingly huge DJ and a great dude plays
a character on this so he plays Jasper
was like a hanger-on really low IQ my
nemesis just because he's like always
sticking in my craw doing some stupid
running late to get on the plane and I'm
always hoping that he'll miss the bus or
let me miss the plane and he never does
whoever there and he gives me mushrooms
on accident and yeah they're doing
because that's so that's Dylan's
character um he's on an actor on the
show so I don't what he studied acting
writing yeah he's a brilliant improv fan
guy too
i he got up and improv with me at the
Mad Decent block party this guy's really
good and Brandon Durham our director was
like you should take it a snapchat and I
did and it's so funny the characters
that he does on there and I was like we
have to have him on the show yeah a
bachelor commentary I decide who's the
best screens until next time the
bachelors on go to follow Dylan practice
on snapchat